living as we did up in the woods in
pennsylvania before we moved out to
nashville we never had to think much
about you know tornadoes pennsylvania
sees its share of twisters but tennessee
has significantly more though both
states are dwarfed by kansas texas
oklahoma et cetera and the tornado tally
so after a year in tennessee it was not
completely out of the ordinary when the
tornado warning started blaring on our
phones early saturday morning this past
saturday morning around 3am
we had a tornado watch before we went to
bed which means that conditions are such
that there could be tornadoes the
warning comes in when actual funnel
clouds have been sighted and you need to
seek shelter immediately
it's always disconcerting huddling in
the basement listening to the winds that
sound like mack trucks speeding through
your yard
but that's all it was in our neck of the
woods lots of wind and noise and some
down power lines and then some scattered
tree limbs and that was that was
basically the extent of it our neighbors
especially to the north and west of us
were not so lucky
around 20 separate tornadoes
including one massive one that cut a
path across some they think 200 miles
and uh ripped through parts of tennessee
kentucky arkansas missouri hitting
hitting kentucky the hardest over 100
people were killed the majority in
kentucky and the lion's share of those
deaths were concentrated in one factory
a candle factory where dozens of workers
were killed when the factory was totally
demolished by the storms in fact almost
the whole town of mayfield where the
factory was located was destroyed
images of the devastation looked like
you know the aftermath of some kind of
aerial bombardment during wartime the
daily wire was on the scene interviewing
survivors you can you can hear them tell
the story in their own words and see
some of the images take a look at this
never in my life seen destruction like
this never
first tornado warnings uh
we had a siren right there so super loud
but at that moment i started getting
mattresses out i was just ready right by
the closet that i planned on it was the
most centered part of the house so
they was making fun of me you know what
i mean but it's better safe than sorry
and then we went out on the front porch
because i've personally never seen a
tornado and uh
next thing you know
got real calm and then i heard something
like a freight train and you know i've
always watched documentary stuff so the
whole all the power went out and i seen
like the tornado looked blue from the
electricity and it was probably about
two streets over that way that's when we
seen it so i immediately run in
the gentleman's laying in bed over there
so i you know i'll bust this door down
tell him get up tornado's coming he
jumps in the shower and we run over here
uh get we get up in the closet and pull
mattress over us the whole house starts
shaking uh you hear things breaking and
i was just praying the whole time you
know and uh it was it happened so fast
and it was calm
everybody got out made sure everybody
was okay and the first thing you know we
thought of was getting out and helping
so that's truly horrifying and there's a
there's a sickening sort of uh
helplessness that you feel when you're
in the path of something like this we
had just a very very small taste of that
uh where we lived
because you know that you're at the
mercy of nature and if things decide to
hit directly where you're sitting
no matter how many precautions you take
you're probably doomed
when you consider the force and the
magnitude and the boundlessness of
nature
it becomes all the more not only
grotesque but absurd after the fact
when the political forces in our country
attempt to turn these
natural forces
into a political issue
that's exactly what happened here as
usual with bodies still buried under the
rubble the media and politicians set out
to make ideological hay out of the whole
thing by tying the tornadoes to of
course climate change and claiming that
that we could have somehow prevented
saturday's disaster through well-written
legislation
there could have been laws written to
stop tornadoes
that's the claim here's uh president
anything to you biden climate change is
this or do you have conclude that these
storms and the intensity would have to
do with climate change well all that i
know is that
the intensity of the weather across the
board
has some impacts as a consequence of the
warming of the planet
and the climate change the specific
impact on these specific storms i can't
say at this point i'm going to be asking
the epa and others to take a look at
that but the fact is that
we all know everything is more intense
when the climate is warming everything
and obviously it has some impact here
but i can't give you a quantitative read
on that yes we know that um we know that
the climate change caused this
i can't say how
or to what extent or offer any proof
but you know just go with my general
statements anyway
it had we don't know how but it but it
happened actor mark ruffalo last seen
using cutesy pet names for child rapists
in kenosha was more direct tweeting
quote this is what hashtag climate
catastrophe looks like it's only going
to get worse from here now it's time to
fight for our suffering and despairing
youth yeah we have to we have to fight
uh tornadoes
let's come up with our game plan
to fight back against tornadoes
rachel vinman a woman with an
inexplicably large following said
climate change what does it look like
this is absolutely heartbreaking and
it's a direct result of climate change
believe me i know it's tempting to
scream yell and question why people are
so slow to accept reality but we must
have conversations with skeptics that's
another thing that will stop tornadoes
conversations
noel scoville another woman with an
inexplicably uh large following
wrote sorry kentucky maybe if your two
senators hadn't spent decades blocking
legislation to reduce climate change you
wouldn't be suffering from climate
disasters if it's any consolation
mcconnell and rand have effed over all
of us too
now she tweeted that by the way
noelle scoville did tweeted that early
in the morning on saturday
so it was like the very first thing she
thought when she woke up to the news
that a hundred people were buried under
rubble across you know three different
states the very first thing she thought
was oh this is going to be a great way
this is this uh i could i could get a
little dig in here against the
republicans and mcconnell and rand paul
the media of course chimed in with
explainers like this one from cnn how
the climate crisis is affecting
tornadoes
and then this from washington post a
warming world could add more fuel to
tornadoes scientists say and so on you
get the idea the consensus from all of
these sources
is that natural disasters like tornadoes
happen because of us
these people believe or at least they
want us to believe which is not
necessarily the same thing
that there is actually legislation that
can be written laws that can be passed
to stop tornadoes
so when they look at a footage of an f5
tornado
and when most of us see footage like
that we see
a force of nature
we see nature in all of its in all of
its terrifying deadly
um you know
essence but what they see with the
tornado is a policy failure
tornadoes are policy failures that's how
they see it
now let's let's be clear about something
here
um
that view to the extent that it's held
sincerely
is straight up superstition okay it's on
the level of like a primitive tribesman
who thinks that he can stop the rain or
make the rain start or whatever
influence the weather by dancing around
a fire enchanting certain things
in fact it's worse than that it's far
worse than that because at least the
primitive tribesman has an excuse to be
ignorant
of the science
he doesn't have access to that
information he is making sense of the
world with the information that he has
available to him the modern climate
change alarmist should know better and
often does but he spreads this nonsense
anyway
now here are some facts to keep in mind
on the issue of climate change and how
it affects tornadoes
first of all if natural disasters were
getting deadlier
there would be a very obvious reason for
that which has nothing to do with
climate change
there are more people on earth so a
deadlier uh catastrophe is one right
that kills more people and if there are
more people around then that means that
more people can die
which because more people are will be in
the path of any given disaster
there are
twice as many people in the midwest
today
as there were in the 20s for example
which puts twice as many people in the
path of tornadoes
and yet
so that's if the if natural disasters
were getting deadlier that would be the
reason
yet amazingly what you find is that in
fact a lot fewer people are actually
dying in this way natural disaster
deaths are
at historic lows not highs in spite of
the fact that there are so many more
people around
as andrew folett who's a former nasa
scientist he explained this weekend in a
very enlightening thread on twitter
in fact
the deadliest day for tornadoes in
american history still
was in the 20s 1925
not even 20 years after the model t was
first introduced
so not a lot of time for um for fossil
fuels to
be creating tornadoes right
and yet 700 people died in basically the
same region where 100 just died from
tornadoes and again there were fewer
people
populations were more spread out less
dense than they are now
and yet the disaster was deadlier much
deadlier
why is that well that's because
it's because of the kinds of modern
innovations
that the left blames for natural
disasters
those those innovations that get blamed
for natural disasters are actually
saving millions of lives from natural
disasters
by the way the deadliest hurricane in
american history hit galveston
and guess what year 1900
and we know about hurricanes as far back
as the 1600s that were killing thousands
of people we can't go back farther than
that because there was nobody around in
this part of the world keeping reliable
records
that's the other problem with comparing
weather events across centuries
we've only been keeping track of these
things reliably for a comparatively
short amount of time and so it's very
hard
nobody has any idea how many tornadoes
hit the north american continent in the
year 1350 for example or how bad they
were or how many people died from them
we have absolutely no idea we can't
possibly know
did a tornado hit uh this continent in
uh on on march 7th
you know in the area where kansas is now
in the year
1272. do you know the answer to that
nobody
does there was no one around keeping
records of it
there are people around but they weren't
keeping reliable records that we can use
now to trace the weather
and yet you hear things like oh it was
the worst storm in
well how do you know that
what that always means is worst storm by
certain metrics we think
since we started keeping track a few
decades ago
that's what worst in history means when
it comes to weather events
remember something
um the earth is enormous
and ancient
it didn't begin at the dawn of the
industrial age
despite what you may have heard
go back to the year
700 million bc
and there were weather events going on
far more extreme than what we
experienced today
and the climate was changing and the
climate changes were far more drastic
and devastating
just there were no people around to be
affected by it
go forward to the year 770 000 bc let's
see let's say
and you'll see the earth getting
battered by all kinds of extreme weather
events
same in the year 7000 bc and 1000 a.d
in the year 1550 in 1650 and 1721 and
now in 2021 and yet after these billions
of years of history
where the earth has endured one
catastrophe after another we we step
into this chain of events in modern
times and surmise that it's all our
fault
and that we can actually stop it
by writing words on a piece of paper
and having a bunch of politicians sign
it
the amount of ego required to believe
this is almost impossible to fathom
and yet at the same time
i can see why it's appealing in a
certain way
because i go back to that feeling of
dread when the tornado warning sounds
and you'll you're huddle you're huddled
in your your safe place that they tell
you to go to and you've got your kids
and your families there
and it's only safe so long as the
tornado doesn't get too close to it
right
it is it's scary to be so powerless and
vulnerable
in the face of these things that we
can't control so there's a comfort then
in climate change hysteria
that's one of the great lessons of the
last couple of years especially is that
there's a comfort for people find
comfort in hysteria
believe it or not
because it convinces you that you can
conceivably control the uncontrollable
and that you are not at the mercy of
forces beyond you
but that's all a lie
it's an illusion
[Music]
stop fooling yourself and face reality
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content